Translator: Andrea McDonough
Reviewer: Jessica Ruby
I think the most interesting job
that's going to exist probably in the next ten years
is going to be a space miner.
So, this is going to be somebody
who's going to be mining asteroids in space
because there's a lot of minerals
that we need these days
to make the technologies that we use everyday,
including your cellphone,
your computer,
and there's a limited number of them on Earth,
but we know that they exist in space.
And so, as our capabilities to go to space,
look at, say, the Mars Curiosity rover
that's now driving around the surface of Mars
and the new Mars I initiative
to send a, start a colony on Mars,
I think that, you know,
space is really where there's incredible opportunity.
And so, I think it's going to be fascinating
to see the day when we have people
that are working in space
on asteroids.
Click any of these fortune cookies
to see your questions and follow-up questions explored.
Click this cookie to return to the intro video
and see what this series is all about,
or click this cookie to suggest
alternative questions,
participants,
or career paths
for future videos.